nice
kind of an amazing day right
very surreal
man that's a really hard question right
you have to change your entire body and
jump into a script and you wouldn't know
the lines and be like the high school
anxiety dream I don't think I have a
good answer there's certainly a lot of
films to admire but I'm happy with what
I did
other filmmakers
and make things happen
you did
you know I think there's so many people
have also hard who deserve these sorts
of opportunities I think it was a
combination of working really hard and
having some really good luck
a lot of its look and I think a lot of
it is being ready for a good opportunity
and working hard okay
did you load your
a little shame
give me
I'm not sure I'm there yeah that's from
there okay my there I think you're here
thank you
and just last but not least
I think you know I had a job taking
party pictures so it was being
surrounded by really happy people who
put cigarettes out on you as you tried
to make them look beautiful right that
was a pretty hard thank you so much
thank you thank you so much
I